in the last video I drew this grid in
order to understand better the different
combinations of alleles I could get from
my mom or my dad and this grid that I
drew is called a punnett square punnett
punnett square and I looked up what
punnett means and it turns out and this
this might be the biggest takeaway from
this video that when you go to the the
farmers market or you go to the produce
and you you see those little baskets you
see those little baskets that often
you'll see maybe strawberries or
blueberries sitting and they have this
little grid here right there sometimes
grapes are in them and you you have a
bunch of strawberries in them like that
that green basket is a Punnett that's a
Punnett apparently in some countries
they call it a pond it I think England's
one of them and you UK viewers can
correct me if I'm wrong and so I guess
that's where the inspiration comes from
for but calling these punnett squares
that these are kind of these little
green baskets that you can throw
different combinations of genotypes in
and these punnett squares aren't just
useful if you're talking about crossing
two hybrids this is called a monohybrid
cross because you're crossing two
hybrids for only one trait it could be
useful for a whole set of different
types of crosses between two to two
reproducing organism and it doesn't even
have to be a situation where where one
thing is dominating another let's let's
do a bunch of these just to make you
familiar with the ideas so let's say you
have a mom so instead of doing two
hybrids let's do say the mom I'll keep
using the blue eye brown-eyed analogy
just because we're already reasonably
used useful to it let's say the cheese
homozygous dominant and let's say that
the dad the dad is is it is a
heterozygote so he's got a brown and
he's got a blue and we want to know the
different combinations of genotypes that
one of their children might have so what
we do is we draw up punnett square again
so let me draw a grid here
draw grid right there and up here will
write the different gene that mom can
contribute and here will write the
different genes that dad can contributor
the different alleles I didn't want to
write gene I wanted to write dad all
right so the mom
in either case is either going to
contribute this big B brown allele from
one of the homologous chromosomes or on
the other homologous well they has the
same allele so it's going to contribute
that one to her child the dad could
contribute this one that big brown-eyed
big the capital B allele for brown eyes
or the lowercase B for blue eyes either
one so the different combinations that
might happen an offspring could get both
of these brown alleles from one copy
from both parents this could also happen
where you get this brown allele from the
dad and then the other brown allele from
the mom or you could get a brown allele
from the mom and a blue-eyed Anil from
allele from the dad or you could get the
other brown-eyed allele from the mom
right these are when the mom has this
she has two chromosomes homologous
chromosomes each of them have the same
brown allele on them they both have that
same brown allele so I could get the
other one from my mom and still get this
blue-eyed allele from my dad so if you
said what's the probability of having a
blue-eyed child assuming that blue eyes
are recessive and remember this is a
phenotype these particular combinations
are genotypes in order to have blue eyes
you have to be homozygous recessive you
have to have two lower case B so what's
the probability of having this well
there are no combinations that result in
that so there's a 0% probability of
having two blue-eyed children what's the
probability of having a homo let me a
homozygous dominant child let me write
that homozygous zygous dominant
and now we're looking at the genotype we
care about the specific alleles that
that child inherits well which of these
are homozygous dominant whether you have
this one right here and you have that
one right there and so two of the four
equally likely combinations are
homozygous dominant so you have a 50%
shot and we can do these punnett squares
they don't even have to be for
situations that where one trait is
necessarily dominant on the other for
example you could have the situation
it's called incomplete dominance so
incomplete dominance in complete
dominance let's say you have two traits
for color in an hour
you can have you could have red flowers
or you could have white flowers or you
could have white flowers and let's say I
were to cross a parent flower where that
has the genotype capital R I'll just
make it in a capital W so that could be
the mom or the dad or the analogy breaks
down a little bit with parents although
there is a male and a female that
sometimes on the same plant and let's
say the other plant is also a red and a
white so the other plant has a red
allele and also has a white allele so
what are the different possibilities
well we just draw our punnett square
again let me draw our little grid so the
child can inherit both of these red
alleles could inherit this white allele
and then this red allele so this red one
and then this white one right that's
that right there and that red one is
that right there or could inherit this
red one from let's say this is the mom
plant and then the white allele from the
dad plant so that's that one right there
or you could inherit both white alleles
now what I said when I went into this
and I wrote it at the top right here is
we're studying a situation dealing with
incomplete dominance so what does that
mean well that means you might actually
have mixing or blending blending of the
traits when you actually look at them so
if this was complete dominance if red
was dominant to white did he say okay
all of these guys are going to be red
and all and these guy only this guy
right here is going to be white so you
have a 1 in 4 probability of being white
but let's say that a header is a
heterozygous genotype so let's let me
write that down let's say if I let's say
that are when you have one R allele and
one white allele that this doesn't
result in red this results in pink
this results in pink so this is what
blending is it's kind of a mixture of
the two so if I said if these two people
were to these two plants were to
reproduce and the traits for red and
white petals I guess we could say are
incomplete dominant or or incompletely
dominant or they blend and if I were to
say what's the you know what what's the
probability of having a pink plant and
now when I'm talking about pink this of
course is a phenotype so the probability
of pink well let's look at the different
combinations how many of these are pink
this one is pink and this is pink so to
our pink of a total of four equally
likely combinations so it's a 50% chance
it's a 50% chance that were pink and
that we could keep doing this over
multiple generations say Oh what happens
in the second in the third and the
fourth generation actually we could even
have a situation where we have multiple
different alleles and I'll use the get
almost a kind of a more realistic
example I'll use blood types as an
example so there are three potential
alleles for blood type three potential
alleles you can have a blood type a you
could have a lot of blood type B or you
could have a blood type O you could have
a blood type O and what happens is if
you have a combination here between
codominance and recessive genes and I'm
going to show you what I talked about
when we when we do the punnett squares
maybe I'll stick to one color
I think you're getting the idea so let's
say I have a parent who is a B so that
means that they have one on one of their
homologous chromosomes they have the a
allele and the other one they have the B
allele that's what a B means so the
phenotype is the genotype there
codominant they both express themselves
they don't necessarily blend they both
express that's an a/b blood type so this
is let me write this right here this is
a B blood type blood type and then the
other parent let's say the other parent
is let's say let's say that they are
they are fully an a blood type let's say
they're an a blood type let's say their
phenotype is an a blood type and I'm not
confusing you but their genotype is that
they have one allele that's an A and
their other alleles that's an O so this
is what's interesting about blood types
it's a mixture o is recessive o is
recessive while these guys are
codominant so if you have either of
these guys with a know these guys
dominate if you have them together then
your blood type is a B so what are all
the different combinations for these for
this this couple here for this couple
right here well you could get this a and
that a so you get a from your mom and
you get an A from your dad right there
and if clearly in this case you'll have
your phenotype you will have an a blood
type in this situation you could get the
a from your dad and you could get the B
from your mom in which case you have an
A B blood type you could get the a from
your mom
and the O from your dad in which case
you have an a blood type because this
dominates that or you could get the B
from your let me don't want introduce
arbitrary colors you could get the B
from your mom let me write it this way B
from your mom that's this one or the O
from your dad and there's no what's
again introduced to a different color
and this is a B blood type so if I said
what's the probability what's the
probability of having an A a blood blood
type well and once again we're talking
about a phenotype here so which of these
are an a blood type well this one
definitely is because it's a a if you
have two a alleles you definitely have
an a blood type but you also have an a
blood type phenotype if you have an A
and then an O oh is recessive so this is
also going to be an a blood type
so a oh these are both a blood a blood
so there's a 50% chance because two of
the four combinations show us an a blood
type and you could do all of the
different combinations and you say well
how do you have an O blood type well at
least both of you both of your parents
will have to carry at least one oh so
for example to have a to have an A you
know that would have been possible if
maybe instead of an a B this right here
was a oh then this combination would
have been a to O's right there so
hopefully that gives you an idea of how
a punnett square can be useful it can
even be useful when when we're talking
about more than one trait so let's go to
our situation that I talked about before
where I said you know you have little B
is equal to blue eyes and we're assuming
that that's recessive and you have Big B
is equal to brown eyes brown eyes and
we're assuming that this is dominant
dominant and let's say we have another
trait another trait we call it well I
introduced that tooth trait and before
so let's say little T is equal to small
teeth small teeth I don't know what type
of bizarre organism I'm talking about
although I think I would fall into the
big tooth camp and let's say Big T is
equal to big teeth big teeth so an
individual can have for example I might
be I might have I might be heterozygous
brown eyes so my genotype might be
heterozygous for brown eyes
and then homozygous dominant for teeth
so this might be my genotype this and
the phenotype for this one would be a
big tooth brown-eyed person right big
let me make that clear this is big tooth
phenotype big tooth and this is the
phenotype what you see is brown eyes a
big tooth brown-eyed person now if we
assume 2d the genes that code for teeth
or eye color are on different
chromosomes and this is a key assumption
we can say that they assort
independently let me write that down
independent assortment and dependent
assortment assortment I shouldn't have
assortment so this is a case where if I
were to look into my look at my
chromosomes let's say this is one
homologous pair maybe we call this
homologous pair 1 and let's say I have
another homologous pair and obviously we
have 23 of these but let's say this is
homologous pair 2 right here if I color
is the eye color gene is let me pick a
is here and here remember the both
homologous chromosomes code for the same
genes they might have different versions
those are alleles and if teeth are over
here
so if teeth are over here they will
assort independently so when when after
meiosis occurs to produce the gametes
the offspring might get this chromosome
or copy of that chromosome for eye color
and might get this a copy of this
chromosome for for teeth eyes or tooth
size or it could go the other way maybe
it's another offspring gets this one and
this chromosome for eye color and then
this chromosome for teeth color and gets
the other version of the allele so
because they're on different chromosomes
you can there there's no linkage between
whether if you inherit this one whether
you inherit big teeth whether you're
going to inherit small
brown eyes or blue eyes now if they were
on the same chromosome let's say the
situation where they are on the same
chromosome so let's say let's say let me
pick another trait hair color hair color
let's say the gene for hair color is on
chromosome 1 so let's say hair color the
gene is there and there these might be
different versions of hair color
different alleles but the genes are on
that same chromosome in this situation
if someone gets let's say let's say this
is if this is blue eyes here and this is
blond hair then these are going to
always travel together you're not going
to have these assort independently and
these are called linked traits let me
highlight that so these are these right
there those are linked traits but for a
second and we'll talk more about link
trait and especially sex-linked traits
in the in probably the next video or a
few videos from now but let's assume
that we're talking about traits that
assort independently and we cross 2
hybrids so this is called a dihybrid
cross very fancy word but it's just a
gives you an idea of the power of the
punnett square so let's say both parents
are so they're both hybrids hybrids
which means that they both have they're
both have the dominant brown eye allele
and they have the recessive blue I&E
allele and they both have the dominant
bigtooth gene and they both have the
recessive little toothed gene so this is
the genotype for both parents both
parents are die hybrids they're hybrids
for both genes both parents what are all
the different combinations for their
children and you know I could have done
this without die hybrids I could have
made one of them homozygous for one of
the traits and a hybrid for the other
and I could have done every different
combination but I'll do the die hybrid
because it leads to a lot of variety and
you'll often see this in in classes so
if I'm talking about the mom so the mom
what are the different combinations of
genes that the mom can contribute well
the mom could can
Tribute the brown so for each of these
traits she can only contribute one of
the alleles so she could contribute this
brown right here and then the big yellow
tea so this is one combination or she
could contribute the big brown and then
the little yellow tea or she can
contribute the blue-eyed allele and the
big tea so these are all the different
combinations that she could contribute
and then the final combination is this
allele on that allele so the blue eyes
the blue eyes and the small teeth so
that's for Mom and of course dad could
contribute the same different
combinations because dad has the same
genotype
let me write that down so brown eye let
me just write it like this so I don't
have to keep switching colors actually I
want to make them a little closer
together because I'm going to run out of
space otherwise nope let me do it like
that
okay brown eye so the dad could
contribute the big the big teeth or the
little teeth along with the brown-eyed
gene or if he could occur if you the
blue-eyed gene or the blue-eyed allele
and in combination with the big teeth or
the yellow teeth a synapse elt the
little teeth that would be a different
gene for yellow teeth or maybe that's an
environmental factor so these are all
the different combinations that can
occur for their offspring so let's draw
call this with maybe a super punnett
square because we're now dealing in a
set of four combinations we have 16
combinations 16 combinations looks like
I ran out of ink right there let me
write that it's it's strange why 16
combinations let me write that out
something's wrong with my tablet maybe
there's something weird okay so there's
16 different combinations and let let's
write them all out and I'll just stay in
one maybe neutral color so I don't have
to keep switching I could get this
combination so this big blue big brown
eyes from my mom brown eyes from my dad
allele so it's brown brown and then big
teeth from both I could have this
combination so I have capital B in a
capital B and then I have a capital T
and a lowercase T and then I let's just
keep moving forward so I could get a
capital B and a lowercase B with a
capital T and a capital T a big B
lowercase B capital T lowercase T and
I'm just going to go through these
superfast it's going to take forever so
capital B from here capital B from there
capital T lowercase T from here capital
B from each and then lowercase T from
each you have a capital B and then a
lowercase B from that one and then a
capital T from the mom lowercase T from
the dad I think hopefully you're not
getting too tired here and so then you
have a capital B from your dad and then
a lowercase B from your mom two
lowercase T's actually let me just pause
and fill these in because I don't want
to waste your time there I've saved you
some time and I've filled in every
combination similar to what happens on
many cooking shows but now that I've
filled in all the different combinations
we can talk a little bit about the
different phenotypes that might be
expressed from this dihybrid cross for
example how many of these are going to
exhibit brown eyes and big teeth so big
teeth brown-eyed kids big teeth big
teeth let me write this down here so if
I want big teeth big teeth and brown
eyes brown eyes
so my pen doesn't brown eyes so how many
are the big teeth and brown eyes so we
have to just they're both the dominant
so if you have either a capital B or a
capital T in any of them you're going to
have big teeth and brown eyes so this is
big teeth and brown eyes this big teeth
right here brown eyes they're big teeth
I'm going to say this is a brown eyes
and big teeth because that's the order
that I wrote it right here brown eyes
and big teeth brown eyes and big teeth
even though I have a recessive trait
here the brown eyes dominate and I had a
small teeth here but the big teeth
dominate this is brown eyes and big
teeth this is brown eyes and big teeth
let's see this is brown eyes and big
teeth brown eyes and big teeth and let
me see if I all of them well no this is
brown eyes little teeth this is brown
eyes and big teeth right there and this
is also brown eyes and big teeth they're
heterozygotes for each trait but both
brown eyes and big teeth are dominant so
these are all phenotypes of brown eyes
and big teeth so how many of those do we
have we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 of those
so we have 9 9 brown eyes and big teeth
now how many do we have of big teeth
so let me write big more let me write
different colors so let me write brown
eyes brown eyes and little teeth little
teeth something my pen tablet doesn't
work quite right over there so brown
eyes and little teeth so see this is
brown eyes and little teeth right there
this is brown eyes and little teeth
right there this is brown eyes and
little teeth right there so there's
three combinations of brown eyes and
little teeth three and if I were to say
blue eyes blue eyes blue and big teeth
big teeth what are the combinations
there well this is blue eyes and big
teeth blue eyes and big teeth blue eyes
and big teeth so there's three
combinations there and then if I want to
be recessive on both traits so if I want
let me do this I'm going to I want blue
eyes blue and little teeth little teeth
there's only one after they're out of
the sixteen there's only one situation
where I inherit the recessive trait from
both parents for both traits so if you
look at this and you say hey what's the
probability so there's only one of that
what's the probability of having a big
teeth brown-eyed child and these are all
the phenotypes there are 16 different
possibilities here right there's 16
squares here a nine of them describe the
phenotype of big teeth and brown eyes so
there's a 9/16 chance so it's 9 out of
16 chance of having a big teeth
brown-eyed child what's the probability
of a blue-eyed child with little teeth
one in sixteen one in sixteen so
hopefully in this video you've
appreciated the power of the punnett
square that it's a useful way to explore
every different combination of all of
the genes it doesn't have to be only one
trade it can be in this case where
you're doing two traits that Express
that show dominance but they assort
independently because they're on
different chromosomes you could use it
where did I do it over here you could
use it to explore incomplete dominance
when there's blending where red and
white made pink genes or you could even
use it when there's codominance and when
you have multiple alleles where it's not
just two different versions of the gene
there's actually three different
versions so hopefully you've enjoyed
that